bonjour monsieur bikers merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu à la cour des comptes réclame
donc la totalité des dons pour la
restauration soit 825 millions d'euros
une enquête administrative a été demandé
quels sont les scénarios possibles
autour de cette affaire alors déjà on
peut se réjouir vraiment de
l'intervention de la cour des comptes
qui est donc une institution
indépendante et qui apporte un petit peu
voire gars je dirais extérieur et la
cour des comptes dit dit deux choses
elle regrette tout d'abord qu'il n'y ait
pas eu effectivement une enquête
administrative diligentée par le
ministère de la culture
et ça d'autant plus que finalement les
acteurs ce qui était en charge de la
cathédrale c'est à dire le les
entreprises
l'architecte les principaux
fonctionnaires en charge de ce dossier
sont toujours en charge de voilà du même
dossier
après la presle incendie et donc
effectivement la cour des comptes
s'interroge sur voilà le fait qu'on
n'ait pas essayé de démêler un petit peu
ce qui pouvait être être amélioré aussi
peut-être d'établir des responsabilités
je dirai au sens au sens juridique ne
s'agit pas de culpabilité évidemment un
architecte n'a pas surveillé chaque
chaque ouvrier mais en tous les cas
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
voila ca c'est assez étonnant de voir
qu'on reconduit finalement les mêmes
personnes
et effectivement il ya aussi des
questions d'argent puisque tout ça ce
sont des budgets très important et donc
on aurait pu effectivement s'interroger
sur voilà qui est à la bonne place avant
avant de mettre en oeuvre tout ce
processus de reconstruction
et puis il ya une chose qui est aussi
assez assez intéressante c'est le
financement de cet établissement public
et là c'est vrai que la loi est très
claire l'argent des donateurs doit aller
à la restauration de la cathédrale et à
la formation des professionnels qui sont
en charge donc de 7
de cette restauration et là on voit
qu'effectivement m je me permets de vous
couper quelques instants vous parler de
budget inconséquent rappelle 825
millions d'euros en tout cas quand on
parle de dons ou et concrètement cet
argent aujourd'hui et c'est à qui le
gérait alors cet argent c'est ce sont
des promesses donc pour encore 600
millions millions d'euros c'est à dire
qu'il ya 200 millions qui ont
effectivement été été données et donc
donc il faut que c'est que ces promesses
encore se concrétise et donc la cour des
comptes considère qu'il faut
effectivement amené vraiment de la
clarté et que la gestion soit absolument
r pour justement à ces actions réalisées
est restée la plus généreuse excuser ou
julien lacaze je crois qu'il ya des
petits problèmes de connexion est ce que
c'est ce que vous êtes encore avec nous
est ce que vous nous entendez oui justin
réalisées continué alors voilà donc
effectivement le le rapport le rapport
de la cour des comptes est tout à fait
bienvenu puisqu'il faut que ces 600
millions d'euros de dons soit réalisé
donc cette idée effectivement de
clarifier exactement où va l'argent et
que le financement de cet établissement
public soit saisie dirait par le par le
ministère de la culture nous semble une
très bonne chose d'autant que ces
d'établissement public sera également
chargé de gérer de la question des
abords de la cathédrale qui sont des
choses qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas été un
autre à notre sens assez discuté un
puisqu'il ya des projets qui sont la
réactivation en fait d'un vieux projet
qui a été élaboré par dominique perrault
en 2016 qui effectivement qui touche 10
toof les quais qui bordent la cathédrale
qui touche aussi le parvis m'a vu des
projets le parvis antilles
envie très et dans l'idée de faire
finalement un grand notre dame
comme on avait fait un grand lourd avec
des parties évidemment commercial de
restauration et tout ça et va être pris
en charge par cet établissement public
donc mais les gens effectivement nous
parlons pas de nom pas de données ils
ont donné uniquement pour la
restauration mais qu'il faudrait
vraiment faire la part des choses et que
cet établissement public est destiné à
restaurer la cathédrale mais aussi
horaires réaménagés je dirais les abords
de la cathédrale soient financés
directement par ministère de la culture
de façon à ce que tous les noms aille
véritablement à la restauration de la
cathédrale m'agite 5 millions d'euros de
budget donc c'est quand même assez assez
conséquent il faudrait quelque chose
soit rien de ce point de vue là
merci beaucoup julien lacaze d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes président de
sites et monuments merci beaucoup